for the people watching and for
us listening
how did you take from like i'm working
in the club i'm promoting i'm this and
that because that's a lot of people in
miami's hustle
how did you convert that into finance
how did you build that lane for yourself
yeah that's it thank you for that
question there's actually a partis a
question that i actually wanted to do
because we talked about rafael nadal not
drinking for four months and he
basically said i had to sacrifice and i
had to basically
there's certain things i had to give up
he's from spain i guess you know they do
a little wine over there the hardest
thing that i had to do being in the
nightlife business
is i said i if i'm in miami and with my
connections and my inroads with this i
need to get the hell out of here and i
moved to boca for when i was 27 years
old and i got out of the environment of
partying and then i had no partying and
i immersed myself in a totally new
career so
what i had to do sometimes you need to
go ghost for a while sometimes you need
to say look
the the environment that i'm in is not
conducive to where i want to be so let
me remove myself from this because i'm
going to get text i'm going to get calls
yo what up we're out you know you only
come by i say what like i'm in boca bro
you know i'm an hour away i'm not
driving down on a random tuesday night
to hit the club
and yes for the first year it sucked the
first year i did the financial i was a
cold caller basically which is just
smiling and dialing i made
five thousand dollars in my first year
five grand in a year i was crashing on
couches but i was away from it all i
said i'm going to figure this out the
next year i made a hundred grand i'm
doing the
five to a hundred exactly but so what
did you do like how did you how did you
create yourself i just doubled down on
getting good at this one particular
skill set sales and finance sales
exactly and then with that commissioned
networking you know not being afraid
getting up there like almost like a
comedian it is like almost like a
comedian
you know when a comedian's not going to
be good they kind of get up and they're
like hey you know so i'm really nervous
right now but like i just wanted to like
and versus the community gets up there
with confidence he's like what up how we
all feeling out there tonight all right
give it up for the last commit like
there's a different like you need to
build up
that that muscle of confidence that's
imperative if you're going to be in
sales or whether you're a performer or
whether you're a comedian dancer
whatever it is
confidence is attractive how did you get
that confidence
well i'm just kind of born with it if
you know maybe it's maybelline maybe
it's better
now we
[Laughter]
no i don't think i think i've always
been confident but i wasn't confident at
this
particular skill set right so how did
you get confident practice practice
practice practice practice practice
getting good at something getting good
at something exactly what does malcolm
gladwell sell say in his book you know
you have to do something for 10 000
hours to become an expert at it i did
that so rather than partying rather than
do going out doing all that i doubled
down on this particular thing and now
it's just going off without clockwork
and that's actually
at a networking event i that's where i
met pbd pat
and 10 years later we just kept in touch
kept in touch and now i'm on
valuetainment i have my own show and
it's just
the compound interest effect of getting
good at something and networking and
having here it is
a positive attitude
having a positive attitude there's
something so
attractive of just being positive
okay energy good energy
and attitude like as awesome and as
pretty and as cool as you guys are if
you had attitudes how long would it be
until like you know
amber really got she's she's she's got
just kind of this like stuck-up attitude
it's not i literally got branded at
birth what's that amber joy amber joy
there it is that's it like i was a happy
kid always attitude is a big freaking
deal
um so what would you tell people who
don't have a good attitude
like how can they how can they work on
that well i'm not the attitude expert
but just knowing that your ego is not
the amigo
and that you've got so many of those
smiling and dialing i don't know
ego nothing i don't
everyone can improve somehow
everyone can improve somehow awareness
exactly what you know you got to look in
the mirror
and figure out you know there's so many
people out there that it's like my boss
sucks man you know i hate this thing
it's it it's like there's always that
person that it's their fault and it
wasn't me and i would have kept the
thing but they said it's so hard to be
like dude
you were late to work five times this
this month you know you you you didn't
actually put in the work
you know if you're supposed to read the
the book or the whatever you didn't kind
of read it you didn't show up to the
meeting you you you just you it's so
hard to be like i gotta improve i gotta
get better i gotta get faster i gotta
get stronger i gotta become a better
dancer i gotta get funnier i gotta sit
and write the jokes i kind of suck at
this dance move let me [ __ ] figure
this out it's so hard to do that it's so
easy to say well the booker doesn't like
me and they just kind of you know or
like the dance instructor she just
doesn't like me it's so hard to be like
i got to get better yes and i do want to
add this
i'm really big on the attitude of
gratitude there it is so when you have a
moment where you feel stuck or stressed
out or like you feel like you're
negative nancy literally just list five
things that you're grateful for in your
head yep and it gets you back to that
moment of just let me show up in a
positive light instead of being
confidence comes from being happy
internally so if you're trying to look
for your confidence
go back to the source what is not making
you happy fix it not from external
things fix it on your own and when
you're happy you have the energy to go
after things when you're constantly in a
bad mood it takes up all of your your
mental space
there's no space left to go out and be
passionate that's why i always say
bullies are never passionate
bullies don't have any space like nobody
who's passionate is a bully in my
opinion because why you're filled with
happiness you're going after your goals
you have time to look and judge other
people and criticize them if you are
focusing on what you do best so talking
about trying to find where you can be
confident take that you know 28 5 000 a
year to you
you figured out what wasn't really
making you happy you thought nightlife
miami doesn't make me happy but you're
like i don't have enough money that's
not so you fixed it you made yourself
happy
and then got your confidence awesome
also you had a good mom that's true we
all have good moms can i everyone yes
shout out to the moms out there i love
you
that's awesome so thank you but by the
way thank you for your great attitude
and thank you for the gratitude of your
amazing attitude not only are they
lovely not only they are smart not only
they are intelligent but they're helping
you figure out what you got to get
better at in your life so i appreciate
you guys jenny and amber being on yet
again
you